Україна випередила Німеччину, Францію та навіть США
за темпами появи на дорогах електромобілів
і посіла 5-те місце в світі.
Вражаюча новина, яка в абсолютних цифрах
виглядає зовсім інакше.
Насправді в Європі та США е-мобілів
незрівнянно більше. Просто в Україні кількість електромобілів
і гібридів серед проданих минулоріч автівок
різко зросла.
В нас найкращі темпи в Східній Європі і навіть в світі .
От в  Україні серед зареєстрованих
в минулому році авто нових реєстрацій
цих перших МРЕО
4% склали електрокари.
Це 4000 електромобілів. Фактично це все, що має Україна.
До 2016 року в країні продавалися одиниці таких моделей.
Експерти кажуть, що бум продажів електромобілів
триває і до кінця року може сягнути восьми тисяч.
30-40 мільйонів від там "Побєд"
до "Лексусів" їздять по нашій країні,
тому 8000 - це крапля в морі, дійсно.
Так само швидко цьогоріч в Україні встановлюють
зарядні пристрої для електромобілів біля ресторанів,
готелів, на заправках, де часто можна безкоштовно
підзарядити автівку.
От, Вибачите, що Київ прямо так стає зелений,
насичений зарядними станціями.
Електромобільних -150, по всій Україні це
порядка 600 зарядних станцій різного типу.
Щоправда, це така ж крапля в морі, як і  кількість е-мобілів.
В ЄС цих зарядних станцій в рази більше.
Зарядитися на них можна за 30 хвилин,
на українських - лише за 2-3 години.
Тож українським винахідникам довелося шукати спосіб,
як безпечно підзарядити автівку біля дому.
Включили в мережу.
Вона по цьому проводу
заведена в квартиру на лічильник.
Заряджаєтсья вона за ніч за 7 годин.
Підприємець Геннадій Корнєв відмовився
від паливного двигуна майже рік тому.
На електромобілі їздити значно дешевше,
хоча самі автівки надто дорогі, скаржиться водій.
Україна могла би швидше пересісти на екологічні авто,
якби держава знизила ввізні мита, каже Геннадій.
В Україні і так продаються здебільшого вживані електрокари.
Саме на них країна і вїхала в п’ятірку лідерів
за темпами розвитку електротранспорту.